es war einmal eine partei für die der
widerstand gegen die kernkraft
gründungsmythos dna und identität war
die grünen
gorleben das zentrum des anti atom
protest das norddeutsche wendland steht
auf gegen kernkraft und kapitalismus
rebecca harms eine der grünen gründungs
mütter steht damals ganz vorn heute
sitzen die kämpfer von einst nicht mehr
vor castoren sondern am stammtisch
rebecca harms ist bei den mitstreitern
von damals und hört zu es geht wieder
einmal um das kernthema und damit auch
um biografien und lebenswerke
ursprung unserer grünen partei das ist
die anti atomkraftbewegung das war der
ur kerne ursprung unsere seele und die
jetzt so einfach wieder preiszugeben
nach 40 jahren kam google endlich es
geschafft haben das wird sich ja dann
wollten diesen konsens den wir hier
erreicht haben dass es etwas was ein
ganz hohes gut ist und was wir gerne
erhalten wollen und das ist für uns nach
all den jahren die wir hier verbracht
haben und auf der straße gesetzen haben
damit die castoren nicht durchkommen
wirklich was ganz wichtiges ist im
fernen berlin im bundestag setzen
mittlerweile
118 grüne volksvertreter mit uns über
atomkraft sprechen möchte niemand
rebecca harms einst anti akw aktivist
innen überrascht heute mit pragmatismus
und stellt sich der debatte
ich kann es unheimlich gut verstehen
dass leute sagen oh nicht schon wieder
den atomausstieg aufkündigen aber was
ich mich verstehe ist dass ein streck
betrieb gleichgesetzt wird mit ende des
atomausstiegs
also das ist für mich das sind für mich
zwei völlig verschiedene paar stiefel
streck betrieb das heißt weiterlaufen
lassen für ein paar monate eine
mehrjährige laufzeit verlängerung würde
den atomausstieg womöglich ganz in frage
stellen
wie hältst du es mit den akw es dass wir
durch den russischen überfall auf die
ukraine zur grünen gretchenfrage nur
drei tage nach kriegsbeginn bei der
frage nach laufzeitverlängerung der
letzten deutschen atomkraftwerke gibt
sich minister harbeck betont pragmatisch
insofern ist die frage eine relevante
ich würde sie nicht ideologisch abwehren
aber die vorprüfung hat ergeben dass sie
uns nicht hilft die vorprüfung ging
schnell am 5 märz bitte der minister die
betreiber der verbliebenen akw es zum
gespräch diese erteilen einem strick
betrieb eine absage möglich sei nur ein
weiterbetrieb über mehrere jahre in der
verantwortung sehen die betreiber
allerdings die bundesregierung zitat mit
voller kontrolle über verfahrens umfang
und tiefe auf der sicherheitstechnischen
und genehmigungsrechtlichen seite das
gesprächsprotokoll liegt frontal vor
bedeutet keine verantwortung für die
sicherheit und keine kosten bei den
betreibern diese maximalforderung
scheint die zuständigen grünen
ministerien keineswegs zu stören
[Musik]
ich finde das erstmal nachvollziehbar
aus sicht der betreiber und ich habe
erst mal wahrgenommen dass die betreiber
nicht rufen hurra wir können und wir
wollen unsere anlagen länger laufen
lassen und so veröffentlicht minister
habeck zwei tage später einen prüfer
merck mit einem ergebnis das die grüne
seele vorerst beruhigen dürfte eine
laufzeitverlängerung der drei noch
bestehenden atomkraftwerke sei auch
angesichts der aktuellen gaskrise nicht
zu empfehlen
doch der versuch eines befreiungsschlags
misslingt
die beide betriebe der drei akw es ist
schlicht nicht machen und sie sind ja
politprofi wenn sie jetzt bleiben bei
einer klaren ablehnung von verlängerten
atomkraft laufzeiten bei den grünen dann
und diesem herbst
wir sollten in solchen zeiten wo wir von
risiken bedroht sind nicht weitere
risiken hinzufügen keine klare ablehnung
im moment die parteilinie gesagt
ende märz und robert habeck vom
kategorischen nein zur
laufzeitverlängerung ab und öffnet die
tür zum umdenken
im notfall müssen wir eben auch alles
tun was die not lindern mitte juli wird
ein erster sogenannter stresstest
veröffentlicht die frage ob die
stromversorgung auch ohne akw es
gewährleistet ist trotz energiekrise
durch den ukraine krieg ergebnis ja
bemerkenswert dass aus dem hause harbeck
nur vier tage später schon der nächste
stresstest angekündigt wird er soll
jetzt strenger geprüft werden ergebnis
in den nächsten wochen es hat auch eine
placebo eine beruhigung funktion für die
bevölkerung es wird gesagt wir passen
uns der jeweils sich verändernden lage
an wir wissen an welchen schrauben wir
gegebenenfalls zu drehen haben und dann
können wir auf solider sachlicher
grundlage tatsächlich
politisch entscheiden der streit ums
atom in deutschland ein vor und zurück
2001 rot-grün beschließt den
atomausstieg doch 2010 verkündet angela
merkel den ausstieg aus dem ausstieg und
verlängert die laufzeiten nur ein halbes
jahr später vollzieht die union erneut
eine kehrtwende
die deutschen wollen abschalten erst
recht nach der reaktorkatastrophe im
japanischen fukushima heute hat die
union die atomkraft wieder für sich
entdeckt und treibt die grünen mit deren
kernthema vor sich her der weiterbetrieb
eines solchen kernkraftwerks ist
technisch möglich er ist personell
möglich und er ist rechtlich möglich
deutschland hat ein existenzielles gas
problem und deutschland kann ein
riesiges stromproblem dazu bekommen doch
welchen beitrag die letzten drei
atomkraftwerke zur lösung dieser
probleme leisten können selbst unter
experten nach monatelanger debatte
unklar
und auch die betreiber folgen keiner
klaren linie mitte märz schätzt rwe die
hürden als zu hoch ein einen monat
später auch eon ist sich sicher
atomkraft hat in deutschland keine
zukunft und im juni sagt der dritte
betreiber enbw steht uneingeschränkt zum
beschlossenen ausstieg jetzt anfang
august die kehrtwende von mbw wir
stünden für einen befristeten
weiterbetrieb bereit
wenn die erstmal sagen das geht nicht
und dann plötzlich sagen es geht dann
sehe ich sofort auch wieder das euro
zeichen da irgendwo aufblitzen also es
kann nicht weiter in so einer krise der
energieversorgung und der ökonomie
solche mitnahmeeffekte geben inzwischen
aber halten nach einer aktuellen umfrage
nur noch 16 prozent der deutschen am
atomausstieg fest über 80 prozent sind
dagegen die kernkraftwerke zum
jahresende abzuschalten und die grünen
haben ist ein pragmatiker er schaut
natürlich in seine
kommunikationsverhalten auf die
stimmungen unter den bürgerinnen und
bürgern das sind nicht mehr die grünen
vor 20 jahren da sind
schweigsame adaption fähige politiker
und politikerinnen geworden es war
einmal eine partei für die das nein zur
kernkraft identitäts bildend war heute
hat sie die alten barrikaden abgeräumt
die neuen grünen haben die mehrheit der
gesellschaft ins visier genommen sie
suchen konsens statt kampf